-You can see her
in the Peacock series "Bel Air."
performing "ICU" from her EP,
"What I Didn't Tell You,"
please welcome Coco Jones.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Something 'bout
your hands on my body ♪
♪ Feels better than
any man I ever met ♪
♪ Something 'bout the way
you just get me ♪
♪ I try and I,
don't 'cause I can't forget ♪
♪ You've got a feelin' ♪
♪ And a soul
that I need in my life ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ And though we may grow ♪
♪ I don't know
why we don't grow apart ♪
♪ Maybe, maybe ♪
♪ Maybe I-I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪ Need you, baby ♪
♪ I breathe you ♪
♪ You're turnin' my heart blue ♪
♪ Maybe I-I-I-I ♪
♪ I need you, babe ♪
♪ When I leave you ♪
♪ I see you ♪
♪ Ahh, ahh ahh ♪
♪ Ahh, ahh ahh,
ahh ahh, ahh ahhhh ♪
♪♪
♪ First we agreed
that we better as friends ♪
♪ And I delete every message
that we send ♪
♪ I try to move on
with somebody less like you ♪
♪ I don't know
how we end up in the red ♪
♪ I find myself
readin' your comments again ♪
♪ And then we end up
in each other's heads ♪
♪ It all makes sense because ♪
♪ You've got a feelin' ♪
♪ And a soul
that I need in my life, babe ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh oh ♪
♪ And though we may grow ♪
♪ I don't know
why we don't grow apart, babe ♪
♪ Maybe ♪
♪ Maybe I-I ♪
♪ I need you, babe ♪
♪ I breathe you, you ♪
♪ You turnin' my heart blue ♪
♪ Maybe, maybe I-I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪ I-I-I need you ♪
♪ When I leave you, babe ♪
♪ I see you ♪
♪ Ohh, ohh ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ When I leave you,
I see you, babe ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Maybe my life's
just off without you ♪
♪ Maybe I'm just pissed off
without you ♪
♪ Maybe my life's
just off without you ♪
♪ Maybe you're worth it
all to me, baby ♪
♪ Mayb-e-e-e ♪
♪ Maybe ♪
♪ M-a-a-a-aybe ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]